well two suspects are in custody this
afternoon following an hours-long
barricade this happening in the spring
valley area near flamingo and rainbow 8
news now investigator david torrence
gives us a recap
this barricade lasted about four hours
we're right near the intersection of
flamingo and rainbow in flamingo a good
part of it was closed for several hours
while crisis negotiators worked in the
neighborhood here behind me we are near
clearwater avenue again that is right
behind the intersection of flamingo and
rainbow we're told that two people were
in two separate buildings on one
property we understand someone was was
in a home and someone else may have been
in an rv or a vehicle
there was some sort of argument where
family members were evacuated from that
home several other neighbors were then
evacuated from the area i spoke with a
woman nearby who said she heard a bunch
of police come a lot of undercover
police come to help mediate this
situation
while we were here this afternoon we
heard some flash bangs go off officers
talking to these people on a
speakerphone and by about 2 30 all of
this had ended right now we don't know
about any injuries but we do know that
two people are in custody police saying
just
be a patient with them as they continue
to investigate here and expect traffic
delays through the rest of the afternoon
we are near flamingo and rainbow i'm
david charns 8 news now